we're here at Cornell University and
this is Kirsten Peterson's lab the
collective embodied intelligence lab so
in general throughout all the projects
in this lab it's about creating large
collectives of robots and minimizing the
amount of manufacturing that has to go
into into it so that we can manufacture
a large amount of robots one of the
projects that is the soft sleeve we have
a set of resistive sensors on a sleeve
each of these black lines on the soft
sensor are made up of a carbon black /
eco flex gel where they're electrically
conductive and when you inflate it
around an object you can map out the
shape of the object by measuring the
amount of time that it takes for one of
the lines of resistance to stop showing
a change in resistance the end goal this
sleeve is integrated into vineyards
where you could have a soft robot or a
soft sensor go up to these grapes at the
grape clusters and inflate it around the
grapes without damaging them and then be
able to reconstruct the geometry and get
other characteristics out of it like for
example its ripeness so you could also
incorporate other types of sensors into
this kind of software using for this I
mean is it fairly standard so I guess
one of the main takeaways of this soft
sensor is that it's relatively easy to
make it's basically just a couple of
layers of silicon and then one layer of
carbon black and eco flex gel and then
you hook it up to the Arduino and you
inflate it and you can get some data out
of it it's a pretty simple setup so the
idea would be that people can
manufacture these sensors pretty easily
right here you have a bunch of output
lines and basically you have an input
and electricity on one side and then the
output and you're measuring measuring
the change in resistance by taking it
out to an Arduino and then the Arduino
you can map it out onto a plot where you
can see the change in resistance
the function of time there's one Arduino
and then there's two multiplexers here
to get the readings out and these are
the one is to inflate the sleeve and
then the other is to vacuum the air out
so this one had needs a higher pressure
to actually be able to inflate the foam
no this is all molded so it has a good
amount of steps in the fabrication
process so basically it's several layers
of eco flex type of silicone i molded
around a foam and foam gives you a given
porosity 50% porosity like 50% open
space for air to flow through it that
creates an amount of fluid resistance
and causes a traveling wave through the
robot right now the demo is yeah for
movement and basically it's inching
forward by having a traveling wave
across the robot but what we want to
show mainly is that you can have a
single Inlet and then have a sequence of
actuations enabled by the fluidic
resistance from the foam inside the soft
robot we have some kind of leak
so you use the compress to build up some
pressure
yeah he's hypnotic yeah I guess
something that we can see right here is
I'll turn this off
so what we're trying to show right here
is that you can have a single Inlet of
pressurization and then using the foam
inside with a 50% porosity of 50% amount
of open space then you can create in
mount an amount of fluid resistance and
then with that you can use it to create
a sequence of actuations the neat thing
about this is that it's embedded into
the design of it right so the foam
inside creates that amount of fluid of
resistance that allows for the delay
between the first leg and then and
second line
the third leg I guess because it's air
air is pretty inviscid has a very low
viscosity so you don't see the
difference as much as if it was being
inflated by water this was an initial
project and then the next step that
we're doing is creating a program that
uses these electrical circuit analogies
to automatically design the structure of
the foam inside so if you let's say I
have a given porosity at the beginning
and then a lower porosity at the end
then I'll have a change in the amount of
delay that certain sections of the foam
give and then I could have a program
even more control over the sequence of
actuation so that I have we have these
fluid / electrical circuit analogies
where you can model each of these
segments each component of the robot has
a politically resistive and a
politically capacitive region and if I
assign a certain value to that then I
can map out the amount of time that it
would take the fluid to reach that part
of the foam if I send an impulse of
pressure of air or water the final goal
of this would be to use that
automatic automatic design synthesis
program to say okay well we have this
robot we have this general shape for the
robot and we want an inlet right here
and some outlets of pressurization at
these points and we want the sequence
back to raishin and and that could be a
for a swimmer or crawling robot and by
using a foam structure and a single
Inlet pressurization source then you
could have the sequence evacuations for
the software watt single wave we're
working on more complex implementations
and finally it can even perform
something called concertina locomotion
and so down to the the hex engine the
control system which is around the side
here you come around the side